have you ever been bullied before I want
to spend some time talking about that
today
so the idea of bullying came to my mind
because last week we were at the mall
with my wife and a couple of our friends
and we were doing a photo shoot then we
came out and I had my two-year-old son
with me as well as my younger son and we
came to this playground and Tico started
playing with the other boys and I had a
ball I was playing with them everybody
was sharing and I gave it to my son and
I noticed my son didn't want to share
with anybody else so the other kids he
was playing what they were really ok
with him not sharing him but this one
big kid three year old kid came and he
started taking the ball from Tico Tico
was not happy about it so he pushed he
Coe right when he pushed he co the
grandmother came and automatically my
instant reaction is was this kid bully
and my son and my son looked at me and
the grandmother I said I'm sorry can you
hang tight for one moment I want my son
to go through this himself and see how
he reacts he looked back at me to get
you know validation that that what
should I do I said maybe you ought to
share the ball with them so they sat
there and they started sharing the ball
and everything kind of worked out it was
a bigger kid boy in them and so I
stepped away from the situation I
started realizing this concept of
bullying because it's coming up a lot
lately and there's so many great
initiatives out there in organizations
some nonprofits some our governmental
programs some of our private programs
that are doing great things for
communities and schools to teach kids
about bullying I realized a couple
things first of all I remember memories
about myself being in a city in Iran
called kadaj and this one kid was
bullying me who was six years older than
me that led to something pretty wild
that's that event right I remember you
know me growing up coming to Germany
living at a refugee camp I was a
youngest one in my class I was being
bullied by other kids in Germany then I
remember coming out here and I was
bullied as well initially and in the
junior high school I went to and then
then later on bullying happens again
when you start playing sports for your
high school high school team or when you
get a job sometimes corporations bully
and matter of fact nowadays I think even
the government starts bullying some
people they pass laws what I wanted to
talk to anybody they say executive order
I'm doing this whether you like it or
not right and so that in itself is a
certain sense of bullying right when you
think about it so we can sit there and
say well what can I do to prevent
bullying from happening
quite frankly the more I think about it
you know you did there's a website out
there there's an organization out there
called the National Center against
bullying there are four different kinds
of bullying right
one is physical bullying your kids being
pushed or someone keeps saying if that
happens I think it happened to a lot of
people it happened to myself when I was
a kid and by the way many of the UFC
fighters and boxers if you ask them in
interviews there's plenty of websites
you can go and study and some of the
interviews they will tell you the reason
why they became a fighter is because
they were bullied too often when they
were kids the same thing happens with
body builders the other kind of bullying
is verbal bullying right somebody
bullies you just team just just
demeaning words to you constantly making
you feel smaller and smaller smaller
they're nowadays there is the cyber
bullying which the cyber bullying is
very irritating because you got the sex
thing you got the texting you got the
Facebook you got all this stuff that
your kids if you're not connected with
them there's a lot of things that could
happen with Facebook Twitter YouTube so
many ways for our kids to get bullied on
social media and then you have the
covert bully and you know I myself we
run a financial firm and we run a
smaller financial firm we have been
growing extremely fast over the last
four years but we have a lot of bigger
companies that bullies us I mean I still
have some experiences I have many good
friends from former firms I was a part
of but there's a couple people that
still bully us covert covert is some of
the most deceptive ways of doing it
because they do it without you knowing
about it right they do it behind your
back they pin people against each other
they're very good at it and I can either
go out there and tell somebody I'm being
bullied on being borderline being
bullied or I need to know that for the
rest of my life I am going to be bullied
one way or another and if I'm not
prepared for it and if I don't sit there
and teach my kid to know in life your
daddy's not going to be there all the
time your mom is not going to be there
all the time son there will be boys
bigger than you that are two grades
ahead of you that will try to bully you
there will be people at your job that
will try to bully you for your position
by creating rumors about you there will
be people on a sports team that will try
to bully you by saying things about you
to other people that is something we can
never ever ever prevent in our lives but
I think what we could do is I think we
can teach them what to do when somebody
tries to bull you physically right how
to stand up to them we can teach them
to respond to verbal abuse when someone
bullies you right and what it means when
that other person is bullying you
they're insecure about themselves they
don't feel good about themselves what
they're telling you is really what they
see in themselves so the mindset is
being transferred to the kid we can
teach about cyberbullying some be
careful when somebody posts the pictures
and tells you to put any new pictures on
there be careful if this happens if
someone is doing this be careful because
the purpose may be this these are mobile
conversations we're having and the
covert bullying unfortunately you just
need to know that sometimes people like
to create rumors and gossip and talk
behind your back we can never escape
that but just mentally and emotionally
if we strengthen ourselves we will never
be able to prevent bullying but we will
definitely be a lot stronger when it
does happen how to handle it when it
happens now in our lives
it's my message of the week to you and
please be sure to share this video if
you see value in the content and
subscribe to this channel
you